we might wonder a little bit about the
nature of human intelligence and we
might reflect a little bit on the kind
of intelligence we've been talking about
in the past few weeks it's been an
intelligence of sorts those programs
support vector machines boosting they
can do really smart things but the
peculiar thing about systems that use
those methods is that those systems
don't have any idea about what they're
doing they don't know anything so they
don't give us very much of an insight
into the nature of human intelligence
and after all we'd like to have a model
of human intelligence because let's face
it with the smartest things around so
there are lots of ways to approach that
question and we'll approach that
question first from a evolutionary point
of view some scientists believe me for
instance that we have a family tree that
looks about like this too small to see
much of that but the main point is that
we haven't been around very long
we humans have been around maybe 200,000
years and the dinosaurs died out 60
million years ago so in the blink of an
eye we seem to have more or less taken
over when you look at that family tree
and a scale where you can see it one of
the characteristics is increasing brain
size there we are in the left chimpanzee
on the right plainly mostly mouth not
too much brain in there that one down
below is a reconstruction of one of
those pivots type my petal Apes from
about four million years ago or so so we
became bipedal a long time before we had
much of a brain
so we might think that well maybe brain
size has got a lot to do with it and I
suppose it does so we can plot brain
volume of the our ancestors versus time
so the picture I just showed you was
from about three million years ago I
guess and then up on the upper right
hand corner oh that's not just us that's
also the Neanderthals their brains might
have been slightly bigger than ours so
it isn't just brain size here's what
that guy looks like that's a Neanderthal
of course on the left and that's one of
us on the right some conspicuous
differences big heads the ribcage is
kind of conical in shape yet a large
pelvis people out make liked to make a
lot of speculations about how they must
have moved around but one thing is plain
they didn't amount to much they could
make stone tools but their stone tools
didn't change much over tens of
thousands of years and that was pretty
much the story with us too until
something happened probably in southern
Africa probably in a group of
individuals maybe less than a thousand
what's the evidence for that the
evidence for that is mostly comes from
DNA studies with a lot of probabilistic
assumptions and Montecarlo simulations
but it seems that among the competing
hypotheses for how we came to populate
the world it seems that there was a
group of us Homo sapiens in southern
Africa that got something that nobody
else had and and and the highest
probability scenario is that we quickly
took over that population of Homo
sapiens dominated the rest went out of
Africa and within the blink of an eye
did that sort of stuff
what's that sort of stuff
those are
on those two paintings are from Moscow
about 25,000 years ago
paleoanthropologists like catters all
take that as plain evidence that there
was symbolic shot and the people who are
around at that time us almost a pians
the head is a carving off of mastodon
tusk of a woman 25,000 years ago also
plainly symbolic people were making a
lot of jewelry and doing self adornment
the Neanderthals never seem to do that
that jewelry making seems to have gone
back to southern Africa
maybe 70,000 years ago people were
puncturing seashells and using them as
necklaces apparently so something
happened and the paleoanthropologists
who write fascinating stuff don't quite
know how to talk about other than say
that looks like we became somehow
symbolic and somehow that has something
to do with language so if you talk to me
Tom ski he will say let me get this
precise this is nearest quotation I
expect as I can get he thinks it was the
ability to take two concepts and put
them together to form a third concept
without disturbing the original concepts
and without limit and each part of
that's important see without limit part
is what separates for us from species
that might be able to do that a little
bit but we can do it without any
apparent limit so that's a linguist
speaking and he talks a lot about the
merge operation and combinators in
languages using terms that are foreign
to us they don't use the term Combinator
it's a kind of computer science term but
whatever it is it seemed to happen about
that time it was didn't happen slowly in
proportion to brain size it seemed to
happen all of a sudden in consequence of
a brain that had grown big enough to be
an enablement but the capability was not
pulled up not what pulled evolution in
that direction so I believe that
whatever that was that capability
enabled humans as humans to tell and
understand store
and that's what separates from us from
the other primates that ability to
symbolic ability what ever it is enabled
storytelling and understanding and
that's what all of education is about
and that's why our species is special so
we're going to talk about today is some
something you might think of as an
instantiation of that hypothesis one way
of thinking about it and it's a way of
thinking about what the linguists would
call the inner language it's not the
language with which we communicate it's
the language with which with which we
think which is closely related to the
language which with which we communicate
but may not be quite the same thing so
many of you are bilingual Christians
bilingual if you ever had the experience
of remembering that someone said
something to you but not remembering
what language they used how about you
Sonia if you had that experience well
so yeah experience of having landed if
you ever had that experience of having
remarried remembering some conversation
but not remembering the language in
which it was cast usually no that's a
common that's a common view you remember
something was said that there was a
conversation that had some content but
if it's with a speaker of your own
language and your embedded in another
place you often don't remember what
language the conversation was in is that
right Juana remembers things like that
not sure so sometimes sometimes you
don't have that confusion she says
because you always speak to particular
people in a particular language but many
people report that they have that
experience of not remembering which
language something was set in well okay
so what are we going to do we need an
inner language and maybe we can start
just by saying let's have let's have
something that looks sort of familiar to
a sweet we have an object and it's
supported by some other objects so those
are support relations that's one example
of what we might call a semantic net
it's a network
it's got nodes and links it's got it's
got it has a meaning that's where the
word semantics comes from or we might
have another example it looks like this
there's Macbeth there's Duncan and
Macbeth murders Duncan and we also know
somehow that there's a kill involved as
a consequence and that ultimately Duncan
has a property
and that property is the property of
being dead so there's another semantic
net recording something that happens in
Shakespeare's Macbeth plot now we can
decorate that a little bit so as to get
a couple of other concepts and play
first of all the thing we've got already
is we've got combinators then come in a
Taurus the fancy name for those links
that connect the notes another thing
we've got is an opportunity for
connecting the links themselves so the
murder sort of implies the kill and the
kill leads us to conclude that the
victim is dead so that is treating the
links themselves as objects that can be
the subject or object of other links so
we call that process reification
now in artificial intelligence cementing
Nets we're all over the earlier work but
you know if you have a big network that
covers the wall you need some way of
sort of putting a spotlight on some
pieces of it so Marvin Minsky put a lot
of technical content into that idea and
created the notion of a notion that
deserves another call a color here he
suggested that we need a localization
process so we have frames so called
frames or templates and a frame for this
murder action might be that there is a
murder frame that has an agent and has a
victim and the agent is Macbeth and the
victim is dumpin so that's a way of
putting a kind of localization layer on
top of what we've got so far
later on I'll add sequence to that list
so this is where it rested for a long
time and in some sense still rests there
because this as soon as you've got as
soon as you got combinators and
reification you've got something that's
pretty here that's pretty much universal
you could do anything with it the
trouble is it's sort of down at the bit
level it's like assembly code it doesn't
have as a concept enough organization to
help you go to the to the next level of
achievement there's also a little
problem here that deserves also some
mention and that is that we have over
this whole thing the problem of
parasitic semantics CITIC semantics
a kind of ugliness that surrounds this
whole concept because when we look at a
diagram like that and we say Oh
Macbeth murdered Duncan that means
Duncan's the victim we know that there
must have been a motive
maybe Macbeth one of the became we all
we know all that stuff and there's a
tendency to project that knowing into
the machine if you've got to play with
your telephone please leave so if if we
project meaning into that that's that's
that's our understanding that's not the
machines understanding so much of the
meaning can be said to be parasitic it's
a it's a parasite where the parasite and
we're projecting the meaning into that
thing putting that diagram into some
machine form doesn't mean the machine
knows anything it might be able to
conclude some things but it's
understanding is not grounded in any
kind of contact with the physical world
so we have to worry a lot about that and
we were we were philosophers would stop
there and go off and write a few books
on the subject but we're not
philosophers so we're going to just
mention the problem and go barreling
ahead so we need to use this notion of
semantic net and we have to ask
ourselves some questions about what
elements of the inner language are most
useful in the end it might be very
complicated but here's usefulness number
one the notion of classification so we
know about stuff and we know about for
example pianos and we know about tools
and we know about max but we know about
those things on different levels so when
I say I'm thinking about a tool do you
have a very good image of what I'm
talking about the answer has to be no
because the notion of the tools very
vague so it's hard for you to form a
picture of what that's all about another
hand if I say I'm thinking about
Mack well this is interesting because
there's lexical ambiguity there you
don't know if I'm talking about the the
Apple type Mac or the Apple type Mac or
should I say the fruit or the computer
so there's lexical ambiguity there are
two levels or more but let's fill this
in a little but if I know about I know
I'm talking about a piano you can form a
picture of that so that seems to be in a
more detailed level where you can do
hallucination at a higher level you have
just a musical instrument and I can give
you a tool to think about by writing
hammer and if I'm going to have a Mac
it's going to be an apple and in this
case I want you to think about a fruit
and down here I can be more specific
about these things too I can add a
slight refinement of detail and say I'm
thinking about I'm thinking about one of
these do you know what this is yeah so
it's not a mere hammer
it's a ball-peen hammer and some circles
is called a lady's hammer I don't know
why but it's what's this for most people
buy it mostly because it's small and
lightweight but in fact it's for
metalworking
just we're taking a piece of sheet metal
and pounding it out into an ashtray or
something or four-cd rivets it's a metal
workers hammer so you might not have
known about that before but now at least
you have a word to hang that knowledge
on it's a ball peen hammer so we have
various levels here going from very
specific to very general and we could
even go to a level of specificity for
pianos by saying that we've got two bows
indoor fur
why is it boughs and offer special and
it is like a Baldwin or something may
not yoga lots of piano types what's
special about place you don't know
because you unless you play the piano
and probably unless you're a serious
piano player you don't know that a Bose
endure for Ariel you know it's got some
extra keys at the bottom and most people
don't know that unless they're serious
about the piano some professional piano
players when they're confronted with the
bows and or fur have to cut have to have
someone cover those keys because it
screws up their peripheral vision and I
hit the wrong key because I'm not used
to having those extra keys at the bottom
so that's that's a little detail about
the bows on door first so you can make
kind of graph and you can say let's go
from who very general to a sort of basic
level to a specific level and so it is
this it is the case in human knowledge
that that graph has a tendency to look
sort of like this so here's tool here's
hammer
here's ball-peen so that level where you
have a big jump that's the general -
basic level transition so that basic
level is probably there because that's
the level at which we on which we hang a
huge amount of our knowledge we know a
lot about pianos and it all seems to be
hanging on that word piano which gives
us power over the concept so that's
example number one of a of an element of
our inner language the ability to
assemble things into hierarchies like
that and to hang knowledge about those
objects into the in that higher on the
elements in that hierarchy
but given that you have elements in the
hierarchy to talk about how do you talk
about them well I like to consider the
possibility just for the sake of
illustration that you're thinking about
a car crashing into a wall so you've got
the things to think about like the speed
of the car the distance to the wall and
the condition of the car and you've got
the period before the crash during the
crash and after the crash so you might
want to think about how to talk about
those objects in those three time
periods so we can do that with a
vocabulary of change and we do that
because we believe that most of human
thinking is thinking about change
causing change and that flies in the
face of what we learn as engineers
because in engineers in engineering we
learned about State and once you know
the state of a system you know
everything you need to know in order to
predict the future the trouble is in our
heads thinking about everything there is
in the world including the current phase
of the Moon is too much stuff so mostly
our thinking we think is is hinging on
the idea that change leads to change so
that's why we have a vocabulary of
change so that so in the period before
the crash the speed of the car is not
changing there's a little notation for
not change no Delta the distance to the
wall that's decreasing the condition of
the car that's not changing but then the
car hits the wall so the speed of the
car disappears the distance of the wall
disappears and the condition of the car
will change dramatically finally after
the crash is over the speed of the car
does not appear the distance to the wall
does not change and the condition of the
car also does not change so that's
hinting at a vocabulary of change and
its use which will be the second element
in our development of a vocabulary of
ways in which we might have constructed
our in our language so this is a
particular idea that's classification
this is transition and in any system
that purports to understand stories
there'll be a heavy emphasis on this
notion of transition and we believe that
it's a I think that that vocabulary has
to have decrease increase change appear
and disappear so there are ten things
you can have in such diagrams I've done
five that's because for each of those
there's a not variation on that so
vocabulary ten things can go a long way
toward helping you to describe things
that are in process of changing or
making transition and we have a lot of
those words in our vocabulary we use
those words a lot in our vocabulary they
seem heavily connected with vision our
friend appeared the cat disappeared the
speed increased so this is a description
of a crash in terms of those kinds of
elements now I say to you how does a
camera work well I could say a camera
works because a photon hits a photo
verse fo toda a photon crashes into a
photoreceptor so when I say a photon
crashes into a photoreceptor why am i
saying that and how does it help I'm
saying that and it helps because it's
the same pattern of change you already
know about wanting to talk about car
crashing into a wall how does that work
the speed of the photon
the distance of the photon to the
receptor and the condition of the
receptor so analogies like that are the
very much at the core of what we think
about all the time in any event there is
there is representation number two
number one is class number two is
transition and now you're ready for
number three which is trajectory
linguists who study sentences often talk
in terms of fundamental patterns that
seem to be in a lot of what we say and a
lot of what we say is about objects
moving along trajectories so we can talk
about a trajectory frame and a
trajectory frame will have elements like
this it has an object moving on a
trajectory that ends up at a destination
it might start out at a at a source it's
probably been arranged by some kind of
agent and their agent may assist himself
in making the motion happen with some
kind of instruments there might be
somebody helping out over here a co
agent well what else could we have
beneficiary someone who is helped out by
the action
sometimes the motion is arranged by a
conveyance so these are a lot of slots
frame like slots in descriptions of
actions many of which involve motion
along a trajectory we have a tendency in
language to decorate these things in one
way or another depending on the language
in some languages the decoration is by
way of position in a sentence in English
it's often by way of a preposition
that's used to help zero in on the role
of a particular role of an object in the
trajectory scenario so if I say I baked
a cake with a friend there's a with
preposition if I bake the cake for a
friend the friend is the beneficiary if
I baked a cake with an oven that's an
instrument the object may be moving to a
destination from a source and if I'm
going to New York by train I put a bi on
top of that if the agent is an in
subject position I would say something
like oh the all the work was done by a
student so those prepositions have a
tendency to help us to zero in on the
actual role of particular objects in
this whole package this whole frame so
this is number three and there's a
variation on this in which there's no
actual trajectory in which case we'll
just call that a roll frame because if
there's no trajectory you can still have
things such as an instrument a co agent
and a beneficiary so now we've got three
representations you might say well what
good are they and you can determine what
good they are these days because it's
easier to go over established corpuses
and say what fraction of those of the
sentences in such a corpus involve a
classification
or transition or a trajectory the most
well-known of these is the so called
Wall Street Journal corpus it has fifty
thousand sentences in it drawn from some
period of time all the language
syntactical language types work with
with that corpus a great deal and we
worked with a little bit too to see what
fraction of the of the sentences or what
the density of trajectories and
transitions are in those sentences so I
have to say that a little more a little
carefully because the finding is that in
100 sentences you'll find about 25
transitions or trajectories so they're
very densely represented they're often
very abstract prices rose the economy
went to someplace but there are they're
still words the denote transition era
trajectory but of course once you have
all this stuff that you have a we didn't
have a desire to put it together and so
the next thing we need to talk about is
story sequences so a story sequence can
be a single sentence and I want to
illustrate that with the one of my
favorites here's the sentence
there I think I've chosen gender-neutral
name so it's not a gate trouble so that
by the way don't call myself Pat because
I decided when I was 18 years old that
Pat is a unit of measure for butter
in any case Pat comforted Mary do you
have a image of what happened probably
not a very firm image you know that Pat
did something but you don't know exactly
what nevertheless when Pat comforted
Chris you can construct something that
looks like a roll frame because the roll
frame for that would have an agent and
that would be Pat there's an action
we're going to put a question mark in
there because we don't have a very firm
image of what the action is any of it
we're building a roll frame like so the
object is Chris oh let's you know that
is the object
so anything else we can say yes we can
probably say something more something
else comes to mind when when you see Pat
company press there was there's a sort
of result and the result is a transition
frame and the transition frame involves
an object which is Chris and Chris has a
mood which presumably is improved it
goes up did you have something like
wandering into a very interesting area
having to do with when you think about
this in another way and think of it as
something moving along a trajectory
comfort is moving if not from Pat at
least to Chris and that's a very
important kind of observation because
what what it suggests is that there can
be utility and thinking of things in
multiple ways multiple representations
Marvin Minsky has a wonderful ristic
phrases which is if you can only think
about something in one way there's you
have no recourse when you get stuck so
multiple representations mean you have
multiple ways of gathering regularity
from the world and collecting it and
therefore that will make you smarter so
yes you could do it that you could do
that and that would be a complement to
what I'm doing now well let me continue
what I'm doing now so what have I done
I've got a roll frame and a transition
frame and the transition frame is the
target of the result slot in the in the
roll frame now we can modify this a
little bit
and maybe we want to say instead of
comforted terrorized and how would that
change things we don't know exactly what
Pat did so the action remains unknown
the agent and the object are the same
but the result here is presumably that
the moved went down with just what we've
got so far we can answer a lot of
questions by the way once we've got the
the sentence understood in these terms
we can say who did the thing who which
is all about and the answer is Pat what
did Pat do comfort terrorize who did he
do it to was the object it's Chris what
was the result
Chris felt better Chris felt were felt
worse so these were these
representations already give us a
questioning answering capability that
makes the it makes that makes for an
understanding of the sentence still we
haven't been very specific so our next
step takes this the same sentence in a
more specific direction so here's the
way that goes kissed Chris now you begin
to get a sense of what's going on you
can form a mental image so that you can
have a hallucination and a hallucination
will also be a kind of frame but in this
case it'll be a trajectory frame and the
object would be I don't know Pat slips
and the destination would be Chris's
lips I don't know is that right it
depends it depends have you all form a
picture of what's going on here so it
will be different depending on whether
Chris is Pat's girlfriend or if Chris is
Pat's daughter or if Chris is a frog and
Pat is a prince yes I guess the way the
story usually does so somehow we have in
our heads all kinds of libraries that
help us to form mental pictures of
things when we see things like hist so
one final one just to show the variety
we could say that Pat stabbed Chris what
changes let's see in the case of kissed
the mood is going up in the case of
stabbed the mood is going down you can
also probably say that the health is
going down and the destination is
Chris's body and the object that's
moving is Pat's knife but you get the
same pattern with both of those
sentences so both of them involve a
sequence that starts off with the action
leads to a transition and a trajectory
and those are all arranged in a line and
that line is something that gives us a
lot of power over the situation relative
to a semantic net so I'm going to
decorate that one more time and say that
another element we get out of our
internal language is sequence another
element we need in order to have and
anything that looks like an account of
an inner language is sequence
because if you think about things being
arrayed in a vast spreading network it's
hard to deal with them but if you think
about things being arrayed along a line
in a sequence of actions or events like
so then that imposes enough constraint
to get a handle on what's going on so
what we're going to call this is the
representation and I guess I'm up to one
two three four this is a representation
of story sequence so even though that's
a kind of micro story it's still an
example of a story sequence because we
get the power out of it by arranging
everything online now do you understand
sighs if you play a music musical
instrument of how dependent we are in
sequence so if you play a musical
instrument you probably know how
difficult it is to start replaying a
piece of music from the middle of a
measure you have to go back to at least
the beginning of the measure and
probably to the beginning of the phrase
if not the beginning of the piece so our
memory seems to be at least in music
very rooted in the idea of sequences and
that's often true in storytelling too we
have to go back to the beginning of a at
least a scene because somehow these
things are arranged in in sequences that
form somehow useful usefulness out of
there
sequential Mis so there's one more thing
we can talk about and that is the idea
of not just the idea of how these
sequences are constructed and what
they're constructed out of but we can
also talk a little bit in terms of
libraries of stories
and when we talk about libraries of
stories we can think about kind of the
sort of standard standard stories that
we have and how they're arranged and how
we can know a lot about something by
what it's superclass's so it's a
variation on the theme of learning stuff
from the super classes so here's here's
an event frame and then there's a
addition to event frames that are
disaster frames and then there are party
frames and you know parties and
disasters are both events and when we
talk about disasters we know that they
in turn break up into a variety of
things we have earthquake disasters and
maybe we have hurricanes and in the
party world we have I know birthday
parties and we have weddings and each of
these types of frames invites us to fill
in particular slots so if we're reading
a newspaper story about a wedding we
know that we're going to be learning the
same sorts of things we would learn
about any party except there is the
addition additional information that we
expect that says something about the
bride and the groom
if we have a raw event and we don't know
anything more about it than that there's
a time in place if it's a disaster frame
gets a little drizzly over here but if
there's a disaster frame frame where you
might have the fatalities and how much
how much it costs if it's an earthquake
frame we need to know the magnitude of
the of the quake and the name of the
fault if it's a hurricane we have the
category and the name so each of these
things up there can be viewed as as a No
not just an example of something but as
a new frame all by itself so as we as we
mature we have these first four things
as building blocks and then we we
educate ourselves and we get all those
kinds of frames that help us to
understand the world but how to fill
those in from a newspaper story can be
sometimes quite a challenge actually the
worst thing to understand is children's
stories because and this was determined
experimentally when people try to
understand children's stories because it
turns out the children's stories are not
simpler than the stories we write for
adults in many cases they are they're
harder if you reached about
Shakespearean plots it's all about
intrigue murder jealousy greed but when
you're talking about a children's story
it can be about anything and worse yet
the children's story often raises
problems that you don't see in newspaper
stories let me illustrate that for you
read that story you have no trouble
figuring it out of course but think
about app or machine it's struggling to
understand anything what's going to be
the problem
it's going to have trouble figuring out
those pronoun antecedents look at them
they're complicated
you
they're the pronouns one of them wanted
to buy a kite he has one he said he will
make you take it back so that's pretty
hard actually the principle here that
I'm driving out is when you have a new
story or any story if you have an old
story but you want to read it where you
want understand it quickly the new
instantiation of it quickly you need to
be sure that if you're the storyteller
you don't add to the burden of the
understanding and a syntactic difficulty
so that's an example of telling a story
with additional syntactic difficulty no
newspaper journalists would ever write
the story like that here's how they
would write it they would even they
would even give you a clue that there's
certain information you're never going
to get like who told the story that's
that reliable sources business so this
brings us to the to the to the final bit
that I want to deal with today and what
I'm going to do is I'm you came into
this class today as a 97 pound writing
weakling you're about to emerge as a 250
pound mountain of a writer because I
want to tell you a few tricks that will
make you usually better as a writer
especially especially if you're Russian
or German and here's how it works
rule one
because they place additional syntactic
burden on the understanding of the story
by the reader
so here teaching so are you telling
somebody about some difficult new
technical idea the last thing you want
them to do is to burden their syntactic
processor with figuring out pronoun I
students so don't use pronouns and your
writing technical writing at least will
be much clearer by the way why does this
especially apply to Germans and Russians
is it because is this is this a ethnic
Marjan slur or it's just the fact about
their language it's a fact about their
language what is the fact why can they
get away with pronoun usages that we
cannot get away with in English yes
because if you have all of your all of
your nouns decorated with with gender
that reduces by three the the the
potential for ambiguity of the pronoun
antecedent so you'll frequently find
that German Russian writers will have
pronouns all over the place that are
perfectly clear to them because of
gender they're uninterpretable by
English speakers when translated because
we don't have the gender to help us zero
in so these things are all have to do
with minimizing extra superfluous
gratuitous unnecessary burden on the
reader number two is don't use former or
ladder you see that those words use
frequently technical writing and guess
what no human being ever encounters
those words without having to stop and
go back to figure out what they refer to
so that's another example of not placing
an unnecessary syntactic burden on the
reader and finally don't call a shovel
a spade there's a there's a habit
probably instilled by well-meaning but
Miss advised - teachers that you
shouldn't repeat words and so people
will go to great lengths to use some
different work the problem is that the
reader doesn't know if the shift in the
word is deliberate and attached to some
subtle meaning shift or if it's just
adhering to some high school teachers
admonition against using the same word
again so you don't want to say oh the
right way to dig this particular hole is
with the Spade and then switch to a
shovel because the reader can't tell if
it's deliberate accidental or a
consequence of just the desire not to
use the same word so this is how you can
with some very simple mechanisms
grounded in AI you can actually make
yourself into a better writer by
avoiding those kinds of things that put
a unnecessary syntactic burden on the
people are reading your stuff
you